last night the state of new york passed
a piece of legislation that would ban
bitcoin mining within the state this is
literally insane that piece of
legislation is now headed towards the
governor's desk if the governor signs it
it'll provide a two-year moratorium on
bitcoin mining now why exactly are they
doing this well they claim it's because
they're worried about the environment
they're worried about energy consumption
that makes zero sense but that's what
their claim is of course there's a
number of different things that we got
to pay attention to as this event
unfolds first who else is banning
bitcoin mining china an authoritarian
communist country that's who new york is
following new york is quite literally
following in the footsteps of china that
ain't the place that you want to be big
dogs but remember at that point bitcoin
miners 65 of the hash rate was in china
china put in the ban bitcoin's hash rate
dropped by 50
but that external shock couldn't take
down the network bitcoin is the most
resilient computer network in the world
if china banned it and bitcoin didn't
care and eventually got back to an
all-time high and hatch rate within
seven months new york it's just a blip
on the radar it's a speed bump and
bitcoin doesn't give a [ __ ] about new
york the second thing is that this is
likely unconstitutional if you think
about what bitcoin is it's private
property the fifth amendment in the
constitution states that the american
citizens have a right to private
property bitcoin mining allows you to
secure and access that private property
and so going ahead and banning it is
literally the government stepping in and
saying that you as an american citizen
don't have a right to private property
it's probably unconstitutional next is
the first amendment software code is
deemed free speech that comes from the
landmark case of bernstein versus the
department of justice and if software is
free speech then of course a computer
that simply does math is simply going
ahead and being protected by free speech
as well yes you heard me right the state
of new york wants to ban computers doing
math these people have lost the plot
they're insane they're out of control
and they continue to violate the rights
of american citizens if this goes to
court my expectation would be whether
it's on the first or the fifth amendment
it'll be deemed unconstitutional and
this law will be struck down next up is
that new york is going ahead and being
discriminatory towards algorithms all
algorithms are created the same how can
you sit there and say one algorithm is
okay another one is not all algorithms
lives matter of course if we're being
serious though new york is literally
trying to target specific computer
algorithms and say this is allowed this
is not allowed at what point did the
government get the right to say what is
the computational output of computers
makes no sense and unlikely to actually
be something that becomes popular across
the country because citizens will be in
an uproar if we start to actually
regulate what happens inside of a data
center versus another data center and
lastly the state of new york claims that
this entire legislation is targeted at
things around climate change and energy
consumption well at what point do you go
after the consumers of the energy rather
than the producers of the energy if you
want less non-renewable energy then go
after the people who are actually
creating non-renewable energy on top of
that the bitcoin mining industry about
60 of all energy consumed in the united
states for bitcoin mining comes from
renewable sources compare that to the
american economy where it's less than 20
literally the bitcoin mining industry is
three times more consumers of renewable
energy than the american economy if
anything the bitcoin mining industry
should be put on a pedestal and served
as an example of where you can use
capitalism and innovation to drive
adoption of renewable energy and then of
course my favorite point is that as the
new york legislator continues to be
abrasive towards bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they're going to lose
tax revenue they're going to lose jobs
they're going to lose economic
prosperity new york city used to be the
capital of financial markets but all of
a sudden the fastest growing section of
finance they all moved out of new york
literally none of them want to be there
why because nobody wants to live in a
place where they feel like their
politicians and their leaders aren't
cheering for their success
new york is becoming china and that's
not my opinion china banned bitcoin
mining and now new york's trying to do
the same thing not only is it
unconstitutional it's stupid and my
guess is that there's going to be major
major blowback here as more citizens
more companies realize that they need to
move to jurisdictions where people are
actually trying to help them be
successful states like texas and florida
are going to be the big winners and
states like new york are going to
continue losing